(laughing)
- Today I'm going to try to lick my cat
using the Licki Brush.
- This is Bubi and I've had
him for about four years.
- This is my cat daughter, Millie.
- My cat's name's Tyrion
from Game of Thrones.
You can hear her meowing in the back.
- Out of the Five Love Languages,
I'd say we're both number one, physical.
- Actually she got more
affectionate recently.
She likes it when I just
kinda like rub my face on her.
- I think she's either
gonna think it's a toy
and attack my face or she's
gonna be really into it.
- I don't know how he's
gonna feel about the brush.
He likes any type of physical affection,
so I'm hoping that he likes this.
You know, maybe it's
something that he and I
can continue to do after this.
First of all, it's disgusting
that it's called Licki.
- What do you think?
No?
- It looks like a sex toy.
- That's kinda creepy actually.
- This feels inappropriate.
- This is gonna be my tongue on my cat.
- (Laughs) Come here.
- Tyrion, it's fine, just relax.
I'm just gonna lick you, it's fine.
- No, it's way too much work.
- Honestly it was a little
difficult to manoeuvre.
I felt like I was gonna
drool on her at any point.
She doesn't really like water
so I don't think she'd be a fan of that.
- I can use it as a brush.
It's not bad because it's
taking out all this cat hair.
- Like, I just fucking love this guy.
He's everything for me.
He's my greatest source of comfort.
I call him million dollar baby
'cause I wouldn't see the
cat for a million bucks.
But I'm not gonna Licki my cat.
That's just where I draw the line.
- It really is a primal thing.
If they enjoy it,
your relationship could really grow.
- Cats think their human
captors are large cats.
My god, if that was true,
that's my greatest dream.